Tucker was getting the views and they
liked it but he was at odds with their
with the GOP machine I wonder if this
play is more so because they want to get
away from Trump and away from Maga hmm
like people were saying it's clearly
about the Dominion lawsuit it's like
well Hannity and other personalities
we're talking a lot about the same thing
too and Tucker actually was rejecting
the the the 2020 narrative from Trump
yeah and he got attacked for it by by uh
Trump supporters that's what I'm so
confused about like like if it was about
the if it was about the election and
why would they not have gotten rid of
Maria Bartiromo and yeah she was way
more into that yeah could he just be the
first Domino
I mean it would be Domino I gotta be
honest it would be like the coolest
thing ever if like within the next two
weeks every single Fox personality is
fired except Sean Hannity he's the only
guy there all 24 hours it's like
sleeping anymore now he knows how the
Amazon workers feel He's just never
sleeping and he's like maybe there
should be labor laws or something I
don't know